david h says both of you guys keep
talking about how the book isn't closed
on supernatural how unclosed is it
uh david h uh
the book is not closed on supernatural i
mean obviously there's a prequel coming
out um
but beyond that as far as
jared playing sam and jensen playing
dean
uh
you know if a new book is released then
i think i would be excited to try and
help tell that story
did you and uh jensen settle
did the dust settle with the whole thing
when he uh announced that the
supernatural prequel and then you
tweeted and all that stuff did you guys
have a talk and have a laugh about it
we we had we had to laugh and cry man uh
really
yeah we i mean
you know we're we're two
grown ass men with with
spouses and kids and mortgages and
uh car payments and this and that um and
so
we
we did link up
uh
or sync up or whatever and talk on the
phone and i've seen him many times since
obviously he just directed we were just
in uh
some city together
denver
las vegas
las vegas denver
uh dallas
i've seen him many times uh we were
together uh
in austin um three or four days ago uh i
love the guy man like and he loves me
back i have no doubt
and
i think he and i would both rather
things had gone down a different way
they didn't but that it's not productive
to to say like who's to blame or what
happened
it's productive to go like
i mean i feel part of me feels like you
know if if you are in a relationship
with somebody
friend family whatever
and you haven't gone through hardship
and you don't really know
it it's once you go through a hardship
of some sort
and then your instinct goes to like i
want to make this right where i want to
say goodbye to this
uh
and he and i both figured the former
like hey i want to make this right like
you know and that's
this is going to sound like
hey everybody out there like go get in
the fight with people you love and
that's not what i'm saying but too
strong of a friendship to let something
like this kind of get get you
sure yeah yeah things i mean
goddamn like
can you name anybody you
you you love and have spent this much
time with as an adult
uh as a sovereign adult human being
that you haven't kind of been like dude
like i wish this was different yeah
i wish that was different so i've said
the wrong things i've acted different
the wrong way this is this thing called
life again it comes back to not being
hard on yourself you know what i mean or
the people you love
we're straight man i mean i i i want to
be really clear
because i know
you know you always see
like twitter trolls and stuff of course
man
all that so i want to be abundantly
clear man like nobody believes in jensen
more than i yeah you said that baby you
said that and i i yeah it's touching
it's touching i think he'll you know him
hearing that he knows how you feel about
him he knows
he knows
you